It was impossible.
It was like he was going to have to roll a one in a hundred at disadvantage.
He rolls to twenties, both in that twenties road,
doubled that twenties at this advantage,
throwing a rock in a hall with magical darkness against this fleeing black
dragon. I had to give him the hit. The whole table was screaming.
Ah, Oh, you know, there's no way he could hit it. He hit it.
And he killed that dragon. I am Joe Meghan. Hello.
And this has Dungeons and dragons.
Support.
Okay. This is from silk, the Crocker,
AKA Crocs fans only, Hey,
people who play Dungeons and dragons out there,
what's the best way to start slash learn slash get into it.
Well, I think there's two ways. You can go one, you can get three books,
you need three books to play D and D you need the player's handbook.
You need the dungeon masters guide and you need a monster manual. From there.
It's pretty, self-explanatory make a character.
You're going to get between 50 and 70% of how to play D and D
or at least all the necessary questions you're going to want to ask from
creating a character. So crack a player's handbook, pick a race, pick a class,
pick your background, get your equipment, set your character up.
Then from there, somebody is going to need to run the game.
So if you're ambitious, she loves storytelling. The way that I do,
you're going to lean into becoming the dungeon master rather than a player. Now,
dungeon masters. You're going to want to read the dungeon masters guide,
get acquainted with the monster manual sewer monsters in there.
You like you don't, you want to throw at your characters, blah, blah, blah.
Then you're going to want it either Homebrew and adventure,
which means you write your own or the other option.
I would say that just simplifies things is to get the starter kit,
which is a boxed set and everything. Once again is self-explanatory,
but it's on a smaller scale. That's how you get into it, brother. Oh,
the next question is from my buddy, Sam Woodward, Dungeons and dragons question.
What's a more dangerous character to have in your party,
lawful evil or chaotic evil. It's a great question, Sam.
And one that I feel like I am uniquely qualified to answer.
I would say the better thing for the party would be a lawful
evil character because at least there are rules.
There are collective goals that can be adhered to. You might have a, you know,
dragon born worshiper of Tiamat in your group, uh,
who plays really well with the group. And there's a collective goal,
but there's also because of the lawful evil, there's a kind of a long play goal.
There's a goal outside of the group that this dragon born Paladin
of Tiamat would be also attempting to achieve,
but they can play nice within a group.
It's kind of like when Magneto came to take over the X,
after Charles Xavier died and they can see eye to eye in a common goal,
but you got to watch out once you start achieving that goal,
because that lawful evil character might flip, chaotic evil. On the other hand,
chaotic just doesn't play nice. I've been in groups in kind of chaotic players.
I've dungeon master progressive caterpillars.
It's like a grant I'm going to gremlin in your group.
That's just going to throw a monkey wrench everywhere you go.
So I think that that would be a lot more frustrating.
You'd want to kill him or throw him out.
The next one is from star Shinobi good morning or afternoon evening,
depending on where you live question for today, what was your favorite way?
A GM has a gay master has opened a campaign or one shot.
We've all woken up at a cell or we're sitting in a Tavern,
but have you had anything unique? I'm interested. Yes.
My friend John castle register this adventure where we were unconscious and we
all woke up, didn't know where we were, had no armor, no weapons.
And we were all realized we were chained to each other on a slave barge.
So we all had to kind of wake up and then decide what to do.
And I was playing a minute tar.
So I started like headbutting our captors off the barge into the
water, and now we're fighting and kind of chained up.
And he created these cool mechanics for us being chained up and how that worked
and how we could try to break the chains or, you know,
work together or how much we can move or not move.
And I just thought it was really ingenious in a very, very smart way of,
of starting out. And then we had to like the guys we killed or, you know,
subdued we had to then, then those became our weapons.
So we were just trying to piece together anything we could get to keep fighting
and get off of this barge and, and fight for freedom.
So that was a cool and just, you know, off the cuff. Okay. Mariah Sanchez,
AKA Mariah in reality tips for a first time dungeon
master, but dungeon master is a storyteller.
You're a show runner of a long form narrative.
That's going to take place over months and maybe years.
So you always want to be, you know, all the, you know, few steps down the road,
understanding how to set up these character, arcs these story arcs,
and that have payoffs down the line. So with that said, you know,
what are your arcs?
What's going to be satisfying to your players and that's going to differ for
every group. So a dungeon master also has to have the type of chess,
like approach to storytelling,
where you're building these tracks out ahead. You know,
your three 10 moves chess moves ahead on the board from your players,
but you're also going to have to be empathetic to the point where you can
understand,
you can look into the heart of your players and understand what each one of them
wants from the game. Someone to hunt for treasure, someone to cause chaos,
mythology.
And deities and, and kind of religion.
And in magic and deep dive storytelling.
So you kind of want to gauge how your players are or what they like.
Then you're going to mold that story and be able to use those archetypical
qualities in order to build, you know, stories and to throw things at them.
You know, as a dungeon master, have fun,
understand your players and prep because inevitably your players are never
going to go where you think they're going to go.
They're going to choose their own crazy narrative.
They're going to kill the shopkeeper that you wanted to have become part of
their group and this great storyline.
They're just going to murder him and steal all of his stuff.
So you need to be for all of that in the moment. And along with prep,
I would say keep lists post-it notes on the inside of your dungeon master
shield with names on them, just tons of names, male names, female names,
human names, Dorman names, Elvin names,
just because you're going to have to be pulling those out of your way more
than you could ever possibly imagine. So that's another, uh,
probably the fourth big key to being a dungeon master is just be,
be ready to pull it out of your.
That gets into like listening to your own inspiration wherever you want the
story to go, or you get an inspiration to take it. Just take it there,
just go there. All right. This is from Turk owl.
That is a Dragon's question. Do robes get to attack twice per action.
If they have daggers in both hands kind of lost on this logistic. All right.
That's an interesting question. Yeah. I can see how that would be confusing.
There's a fighting style where you can,
you can have a second attack and there is a feat in which
you get to add your damage bonus. Two attacks are offhand attacks. So,
you know,
you either need the fighting ability or you need a feat that allows you
to strike with two hands. You were talking daggers here.
So we're talking about a small weapon rather than a large weapon,
which gets into a whole other thing,
because there are feats for fighters in which they can carry heavy weapons in
both hands. This is from at optional rule.
I break his knees in quotations, many,
a D and D or tabletop role-playing game,
game master looks on and horror as a player's torture simply doesn't do what
they want. How do you handle this in your games? Do you overlook it?
Penalize them, encourage them. Hey, I'm just the referee.
I just set up the world. I'm just the voyeur. I mean, don't get me wrong.
I'm also the architect of the long form story.
So I'm the one who's setting. The, the tracks down.
You can gently nudge people in the storylines that you think are going to be
really interesting, but inevitably it's up to them.
Cause they may decide to go the other way. So you need to be ready for that.
And with that said,
the beauty of role-playing is that you can do whatever you want.
If they want to kill and torture the shopkeeper, they can do that.
They can do whatever they want. So they're going to start with the shopkeeper,
but then they're going to take out the sheriff and his deputy when they get
there. And then they're going to take over this town and hold them hostage.
I always get excited, whatever the players do,
cause I'm just going to go with it. You know,
my players sometimes come across Hill giants in the wild and a fight
breaks out and they kill all the Hill giants.
And then when they go and they search the bodies of the Hill giants, I'll say,
yes, it's interesting.
You hear something making a noise in the pocket of the Hill. Giant's vest.
You look inside of the, you know, the, the vest pouch.
And it's like a little bone rattle that looks like it would fit into the hand of
a, of a baby Hill giant. Oh, and what's this, it's a,
it's a taxidermied Fox. That's been stuffed like a,
like a child's toy somewhere off in the distance. You swear, you hear the,
the think sound of a baby, you know? So it's like,
you just wiped out all the village of L giants and you think, yeah, we did it.
And now I'm going to make you feel bad because you left all these like orphaned
Hill, giant babies out there, screaming in the night. So it's like,
I always try to make my players feel bad about wiping things
out because there's so much just hen tromping off and
lighting people on fire in D and D that a lot of times the humanitarian angle
never gets covered, you know, but that's kind of the sense of humor that I,
I have of my players. You know, like I said, man, it's just have fun with it.
Let it go. It's not up to you. It's up to them.
And then you just start guiding it where you want it to go.
Because ultimately it was the referee.
You can be as hard on them as you want or not depending on how you feel or,
you know, whatever para basis next Dungeons and dragons question.
What was your favorite character, class and race growing up?
I was big in Elvis because Elvis had a little bit of magic and a little bit of
fighting. And I really liked that too. E dragon Lance,
I was a minutes star. The second you could be a minute tar. I was a minute star,
of course. And now when I say elf,
I'm not trying to get out of answering what's.
My favorite class back in the day, elf was race and class. And you were an elf,
which means you had, you had both, which was kind of interesting.
I love playing a warlock or playing a warlock right now in a manmade dungeon in
the manmade campaign. And man, there's just so many tricks up their sleeve.
So for me,
I love playing characters that have tons of options.
Like I have a high-level sorcerer that I love playing because along with the
Metta magic,
and then you really have tons of options and ways to get out of situations or
ways to be creative or ways to participate in the storytelling. You know,
if you twin polymorph T-Rex is inside of a Tavern,
doesn't matter what the dungeon master had planned.
You're in charge now of the story, you know, uh, you just caused this to happen.
So I really liked being able to really affect the story.
And I find that those spell casters, there's a lot of wow factor. Okay.
This is from J L J dash F last year,
AKA geek bot question is,
is it weird that I practice character voices in front of the bathroom mirror?
No, I don't think that's weird.
I don't do a character voice too much when I'm a player,
unless I'm like delivering some Opus or some charisma check,
but when I've done your master, I, I it's just voices all over the place.
All my NPCs have voices, whether they're a lady,
sweet little lady works Don at the, uh, at the apothecary,
her name's Tony weigh-ins want, what can I get in?
That's basically the Pittsburgh dialect where I grew up. So, you know,
and then my brother will start laughing.
People who've been to Pittsburgh will start laughing people,
even who haven't been at this for start laughing,
cause it's such a rich character.
And it's based on somebody who works at a sandwich shop back home, you know,
that I know. And then they become a character and then, and she gave her and um,
see my nephew Donny in that he's a blacksmith, you know,
and then they'd and visit Don. And he talks the same way, you know, or like,
you know, all of the animal familiars or, you know,
the Druid speaking to animals, then there's, there's all of those voices,
you know, of all of the.
The Christmas, the Christmas animals in South park, you know,
if they talked to a square hole, the squirrel talks like that. Of course.
And then they want to talk to the horse, the horse.
Well,
they talked to a seagull with a seagull wasn't impressed at all with what they
were doing. In fact, he was, he was amazed.
Any of them wound up alive. Uh, I was sloppy. They were, and uh,
they asked the seagull, you know, what's your name?
You can call me and Christopher squawking.
I think you should take it a step further and film yourself doing the character
voices. That way you could critique your performance. I don't know.
Maybe there's some sort of career for you here.
You're going to become an actor or something, but no man, that's,
I totally do all of that. I always developed voices or,
or figured a voice out and then make a note to myself,
somewhere down the line.
I need a character that's going to talk like Ted Knight and caddy shack,
you know? And then when they get to the council's, [inaudible],
that's usually how my DM-ing goes as well. So
I identify, I just pivot from voice, but you can see that it's just,
it's endless, I'm always making notes of this voice or that voice and, uh,
you know, popping those characters up along the way,
Sarah Gushi underscore arts,
what would be a fearsome and evil name for a black dragon?
And what kind of a gem would you give him? Good question.
So I actually just answered this question.
So I designed a quest book for the relaunch of hero
quest. I named the black dragon venom, V E N I M,
which I like she used to take that. And I would think, I don't know for a gem,
I would give the black dragon, a giant amethyst, some gigantic,
huge, massive amethyst that had some sort of like,
even in darkness had some sort of like magical ability to
create light from the inside, almost like a pulsing,
but it's just the way that the light shifts and hits it. But even in the dark,
you can see the light,
sparkling and science somehow it's got its own kind of thing going on. Anyway,
there you go. This is from one Crip.
Wonder what is your favorite D and D campaign setting and why?
I love dragging lists. I just do. I like CRIN.
I liked that there are books that are companions that give you a fully fleshed
out view of the world, because I find that with some of the other worlds,
it's very hard to get the Canon straight. And it's very hard to understand,
you know, pantheons and gods. And I mean,
it just seems like there's so much catch-up work and there are all answers to
these questions, but it's like so hard to find them.
And there's different answers to different questions anyway, with CRIN,
if you don't include the fifth age stuff that was done without Margaret and
Tracy, if you only look at the Margaret and Tracy Canon, or at least, you know,
the books that they, you know, okay, you get this wreck really beautiful,
amazing deep world that involves all the things about fantasy that I like,
which is, you know,
fighting and friendship and family and romance and love my
gosh. It just seems like they're trying to eradicate romance from,
from D and D and tabletop. And so I really love dragon lands for that reason.
It's, it's very human and, um, you understand the gods,
you understand what's at stake and there are great NPCs and villains and things.
And you know, my favorite characters in all of D and D cannon.
So I like dragons. I like CRIN. Um,
recently I've gotten into collecting all the old dark sun modules and box sets.
So, um, those are starting to pile up. So maybe around the holidays,
I'll be able to dive into those. Cause from Matt Holmes,
AKA tabletop painting,
if your PCs philosophy differs from the rest of the group,
do you roll up a new one conformed in a group or see how much you can get away
with behind their backs?
You're trying to make me an accomplice or somehow justify you destroying your
party. Nice young man, there'll be a menace to your, her own group,
you know, uh,
or something where like somebody is going to want to punch you on the way up the
stairs.
Cause I've had players that try to split the party and that becomes their thing.
I'm going to go explore.
And some character dies and people get and they have words with each other about
it. So, you know, it's a team game play nice with other kids in the sandbox.
But with that said like, don't let them that get in the way of, of,
of a great character. All right. This is from Edward R. Curtis,
AKA dimly underscore all that very Gothic,
odd Dungeons and dragons question. Typically, when making your player character,
do you come up with the character first, then the race class stuff,
or the other way around choosing the race class stuff,
then making a character around that interesting question. Um,
I think it differs, I think it just differs from character to character.
I was a kid. We didn't have dragon.
Borns does came around in fourth edition and I wasn't playing.
I thought it was on a D and D hiatus doing like third and fourth edition.
So when I met back up with fifth edition and I saw that you could play as the
dragon born. And then I saw that they were chromatic. I thought, Oh man,
that's like playing a low level. You know,
our aspiring dragon high Lord or someone in the dragon army in dragon lands and
the dragon lands books. And I just thought, man, that is like super cool.
We didn't have, like I said, we didn't have that when I was a kid.
So I naturally gravitated towards picking a red dragon born first.
I like Paladins.
I thought a Paladin was a really cool class growing up and a little bit of
magic, lots of fighting.
Then I saw that there was a possibility of playing an oath breaker if your
dungeon master allowed it. So that's how I built that character. Arc-on yeah.
And then other times it's like, I already know what the character is, you know,
he's going to be a little halfling who has all black leather and a gimp mask.
And he walks around and talks like, and he, you know,
and he's a wild salsa because every time he shoots magic,
he doesn't know what's going to happen. And you know, and you know,
so all of a sudden now I have this little like German SNM,
halfling, wild sourcer that I just cooked up in my brain and all right,
I'll make that character and play him. Okay.
The next one is from the Dan word spiral. I,
if that's a nine inch nails reference, then that's awesome.
Currently making some Homebrew races for my own D and D setting.
Any abstract ideas. Weird as good. I don't know, man. I was thought about like,
you know, civilization of dark gnomes, I've all kinds of other ideas that I use,
you know, in my game and float around. I mean, I'll give you one.
I wanted something between dragon and draconian. Cause I, you know,
I have the fifth edition draconian stats. Don't tell anyone.
So I wanted something in the middle there kind of like a tank that could move
in.
And so I've created these abominations and created a storyline of how they're
being created. And then I just started them up and, you know,
throw them at my players. Okay. The next question is from yum DM,
when a character dies and the player makes up a new character,
what level do you start them at?
An old older versions of D and D first edition, second edition.
Basic you had characters in a party that were all different levels because the
game was really centered upon getting your character to the highest
level that could possibly go getting your character, the best magical items,
the most gold, et cetera. You had players in the party.
You could have a ninth level player with a first level player with a second
level player. Whereas in fifth edition,
it is more centered around the collective story that you're telling all the
characters in the group go up at once.
You don't have characters going up on different levels generally. So, you know,
when a character dies, jumps back in and you might play a differently,
but all my characters are all at the same level.
They all moved from fourth to fifth level together from fifth level six levels
together. So it's easy to just jump them back in at that time.
But it's DM choice. A dungeon magic can do anything. If you think it's better.
Storytelling wise to start somebody off at level one while the rest of the group
has advanced like go for it. That's totally fine. Okay.
This is from Adam trash, mob minis, maybe a dumb question.
There's no dumb questions, but I'm a dumb DM. Okay.
How do I get the players to form bonds between their characters?
Is this a chemistry that happens at its own pace?
Or is there something I can do to catalyze connections?
Good questions.
There's always a narrative story element that can tie characters together.
Whether they came from the same place or they start having the same dreams and
start relating that to each other, that somehow are tied.
They might've been somewhere at the same time,
but you can text them both separately in between sessions and let them know that
there's this part of their backstory, there's this part of their backstory.
But the other thing is, is like, yeah, I mean,
I think it's just going to happen. You know, I had a character who was a,
a bear barbarian and it was just used to taking all the punishing damage and
soaking that up. But there was a cleric in the group and the cleric,
this guy was amazing. He would keep his, my friend, Jason Liles.
He would keep track of what everyone's hip points were, everyone in the group.
And he was like the greatest cleric I've ever played with.
And he knew how many hit points I had as the barbarian and his job.
He would keep feeding me healing.
So my character's job was to soak up all the damage and make sure everybody
attacked him.
And it was this really great symbiotic relationship that we formed that then
became like the storyline where on a role-playing sense,
my barbarian character had done a lot of things that he regretted. And there,
here was this like Holy pious character who believed in this
God and believed that the God could save my, my character soul.
There became this storyline between the born out of the characters, out of the,
both of them where, um,
they kind of needed each other and fed off of each other. You know,
it's really cool when that stuff happens. So, you know,
but there's only so much of it that you can force upon your players at Oregon
rolled a 20. What is your best DND memory?
Um, probably comes from a couple of years ago, right around the holidays,
close to my birthday. My wife, there was this big box next to the front door.
She told me to go bring the box into the kitchen and I did,
and I opened it and unbeknownst to me,
Sophia had had someone at,
but then D and D connect her to Jeff easily who painted all the
cover paintings for the old players,
handbooks and dungeon masters guides and adventure modules.
It's one of the four horsemen, just, you know, one of the great, great,
great fantasy painters of all time. And, um,
she got in contact with him and had him paint.
My arc-on, the cruel, my, my, my dragon born oath, breaker pallet,
and of TMS.
She surprised me with this original Jeff easily painting of
arc-on in front of Tiamat. Like it was the cover of one of those old books, but,
you know, to be honest, like there's,
there's a great DND memory every week in our games.
That's kind of the beauty of it. Something unexpected happens every week.
All right. So that's it for me, Joe Manganiello.
I want to thank the amazing artists and storytellers and
writers,
Dungeons and dragons was really a Fountainhead of creativity for me as a kid is
where I learned how to build a character,
build a backstory where I learned long form storytelling,
as it pertains through writing and producing and directing, and, uh,
really just sparked my lifelong love of telling stories.
So thank you so much for your questions. I had a blast answering them and, uh,
I hope we get to do it again someday. Thanks a lot.